well good afternoon
we just completed uh our second meeting
this week with members of the white
house coronavirus task force
and we've continued we've continued to
be on the same mission we've been on
throughout the course of this year and
that is to save american lives
and work every day toward that day that
we put the coronavirus
in the past i'm joined today and you'll
hear in a few moments from members of
the white house coronavirus task force
including those that are
leading the effort of distribution
vaccinations under operation warp speed
and i think you will be as impressed as
i was
at fema earlier today when i heard the
detailed plans
for the virtually immediate distribution
of vaccines when they become approved
and
available to the american people from
very early in this pandemic
at the president's direction we have
followed an approach
to this pandemic that was federally
supported state managed and
locally executed and to that end this
past monday we completed
our 41st conference call with all of the
nation's governors every state
every territory there we spoke about uh
our current circumstances where we see
cases and hospitalizations rising but we
also continue to speak to them
about uh about the expansion of testing
the availability of supplies and our
ongoing
efforts to continue to drive forward
toward the development and the
distribution
of a vaccine for the american people as
we gather here today
with cases and hospitalizations rising
across the country
president trump directed us to host this
briefing
to describe the ongoing work of our task
force and our
partnership with state and local
officials and our partners in the
private sector to continue to put the
health
of america first but first let me begin
simply by saying that our hearts and our
prayers
are with all of those families that have
been impacted
by the coronavirus over the course of
the past 10 months
and let me say personally not a day has
gone by
that i haven't thought personally about
families that have lost loved ones and i
want to assure each of you that
you will always be in our hearts and you
will remain in our prayers
but we wanted to take this opportunity
also to thank the american people
for the extraordinary sacrifices that
you've made
over the course of the past 10 months
we've been through a lot together
and we went through 45 days to slow the
spread back
when the positivity rate across this
country was more than 20 percent
we managed to accomplish our objective
we slowed the spread we flattened the
curve we saved lives
and then during the outbreak across the
sun belt this summer when we saw
positivity rise to nearly 10 the
american people
officials at the federal and state level
stepped up again
and we put that outbreak in the past
and even as we see help on the way
vaccines being developed at a historic
pace
as i mentioned before as we gather today
we are seeing
cases and positivity rising across the
country
but we approach this moment with the
confidence of experience
we know the american people know what to
do
we have forged a partnership that is
truly seamless with state
and local health authorities and as
we'll describe you today
we've continued to work seven days a
week all throughout this year and up to
this very moment
to make sure the american people have
access to the health care that we'd want
any member of our family
to have as we meet this pandemic now
cases are rising throughout the country
positivity in the last 30 days has risen
from an average of 5
to 10 and um to that end we've
continued the mobilization that began at
president trump's direction early this
year
we increased testing from a standing
start
in the month of february to now as of
today we've completed more than 170
million tests
and we continue to approve new tests
including an at-home test
that the fda just recently approved and
we're distributing more than 150 million
binax tests to
to schools and nursing homes around
america as we speak
our mobilization of supplies you will
hear described in great detail continues
to surge each and every day
we actually are able to track
ppe and supplies on a hospital by
hospital basis and so we're carefully
monitoring we're working with state
officials
with hospital administrators to make
sure that our hospitals have the support
they need
also as we gather more than 140 clinical
trials for therapeutics continue to be
underway but effective therapies are
already available
that are widely known among the american
people and for those
over the age of 70 we're proud to report
that we actually have decreased
the fatality rate by more than 70
percent
since those heartbreaking days of april
in may of this year of course as the
president spoke last week in the rose
garden
we launched operation warp speed
focusing on accelerating the development
the manufacture and the distribution of
a safe and effective
vaccine and you'll have an update today
on the progress from
uh two of our leading experts and those
that are coordinating operation warp
seed
what i want to say in the midst of all
of this to the american people as we
begin
this briefing is that
with the with a massive increase in
testing over the last 10 months
with ppe and medical supplies and
equipment that are available to the
american people
with the medicines and the therapeutics
and very soon the vaccines that are
available
america has never been more prepared to
combat this virus
than we are today but our pledge to each
and
every american looking on today is we're
going to work around the clock to keep
it that way
we're going to make sure that hospitals
that are seeing patients coming in
on an increasing basis know that we're
going to we're going to work around the
clock to meet that need
and you have our continuing pledge and
the practice of experience that we've
had along the way
so in a few moments you'll hear from
members of our team we're going to begin
with dr deborah burks who's going to
describe
what we're seeing in the rising cases
literally every day
for members of the task force begins
with detailed analysis
uh of of what's happening across the
country and she'll give you our very
best
our very best information on rising
cases and hospitalizations
that information is summarized each and
every week for the nation's governors
and provided to them
in particular detail as well after dr
burke speaks we've asked
general david sanford with fema to
provide an update on our ongoing efforts
to provide
ppe and medical supplies to our uh
hospital needs we're we're literally
going to make sure as i said
that as we see cases rising that we're
we're meeting the needs in hospitals
around america to
to stand up the response that any one of
us would want a family member to be able
to have access to
then we've asked dr fauci to give us an
update on the incredible and historic
progress on the development of
vaccines it seems like with good news
happening every couple of days that's a
great encouragement to the american
people
and then general gus purnam will outline
our distribution plans
on operation warp speed i was at fema
today
received a detailed brief briefing about
our distribution plans and uh
and i asked general general perna to
come here today
uh to make that presentation and to the
american people and
uh and it is in a very real sense um
putting us in a position that literally
the day after one of these vaccines is
approved we'll be shipping
vaccines to the american people and
within a day after that
we'll be seeing those vaccines injected
into americans with a particular focus
on those most vulnerable and
and those that are providing health care
to the american people
uh finally uh we'll we'll talk with uh a
bit about
the way forward as state and local
governments
are continuing to act and take
mitigation measures to slow the spread
you can assure them as we did governors
again this week that we'll support
decision making at the local level and
we'll continue to support decisions that
are made
in each individual community based on
the circumstances on the ground
but that being said president trump
wanted me to make it clear that
our task force this administration and
our president does not support another
national lockdown
and we do not support closing schools
you'll hear from dr robert redfield of
the cdc that
actually the cdc never recommended that
we close schools at any point this year
and dr eleanor mccance-katz uh who is
also
serves with substance abuse and mental
health services
at hhs will describe the real cost to
children being away from school
but in every one of these cases we're
going to give you the best information
that we have
up to this moment and i just want to
assure the american people as
i trust that you will have a sense today
that we're going to continue to work
around the clock to meet this moment
but help is on the way we have every
confidence that in a
in a short period of time we could have
one or more
safe and effective vaccines for the
american people
and as each of us does our part in
partnership with state and local
officials
each of us does our part to look after
our own families and our own communities
i believe the day is coming soon when we
will put this coronavirus in the past
with that let me introduce
dr debra burks who will update us on
cases and after that
after that we will get a presentation on
the availability of
supplies that we continue to make
available to hospitals
and health care providers around the
country
thank you mr vice president and it's
really a moment that we want to call on
every american to increase their
vigilance
and i want to go through some data about
why we are asking people from elko
nevada
through denver colorado to philadelphia
from madison wisconsin to el paso
texas and across this great nation to
really
increase their vigilance at this moment
i want to thank the
governors and mayors and county
commissioners that i've had the
privilege to talk to over the last four
and a half months of being on the road
we can have the first slide please the
number of universities
42 states 30 universities and
a large number of chairmen from our
tribal nations
the reason we wanted to really be and
here
is to really understand the reality on
the ground what they were facing and
understand how we could be more
supportive
and this is really a call to action for
every american to increase their
vigilance because of the
graphic that is shown here i wanted to
show you the difference in slopes
between the spring surge the summer
surge and the fall search so the
american people
know that this is more cases more
rapidly than what we had seen before
but to also make it clear like before we
do know what to do
and we're asking every american to do
those things
today the next slide shows our increase
in test positivity
the light brown bars are the number of
tests that were performed
but even with the number and ever
increasing number of tests for form you
can see the increase in test positivity
to around 10 percent in some areas of
the country it is much higher than that
and it illustrates the ongoing community
spread
in your counties in your small and large
metros
and in your rural areas the next slide
really shows the country as a whole
and why we're asking every american to
remain vigilant
to do those things that we have been
asking you all to do
to wear a mask to physically distance
to continue your hand hygiene but really
in this moment of bringing people
together
to really limit interactions indoors to
immediate households when we see this
level
of community spread behind this level of
community spread
is a lot of asymptomatic cases
people are spreading the virus because
they don't know they're infected with
the virus
and so people are coming together
indoors everyone
looks healthy but among those
individuals could be individuals that
already are infected have no symptoms
and are unknowingly spreading the virus
to others
it is because of this asymptomatic
spread that we have asked people to wear
mass
indoors and to ask people to wear mask
when among
others but sometimes when we go indoors
and we're with friends and family
we just assume that if you look okay you
are okay
and now we know that over 50 percent of
the individuals particularly among those
under 35 many could be infected and
unknowingly spreading the virus
this virus increased so rapidly because
there was an unusual cold snap that
began
in the northern plains and went down
through the heartland
where um in the end of september
beginning october a large number of
people moved indoors
so we've been going across the country
to really tell the middle linux
atlanta mid-atlantic states and the
northeast
to really increase testing looking for
these asymptomatic
cases and i really want to thank the
governors across this great land who
have
really heeded that call and set up what
we call
sentinel populations whether it's
nursing home staff
k-12 teachers whether it's community
college students
county workers specific businesses to
really have
routine weekly testing so that we can
see the spread of this virus down to the
zip code
and really combat that with additional
mitigation
the next slide shows what we have been
talking about about the level of
hospitalizations
and in this slide you can see the
hospitalizations by the darkness of the
color and i just want to make it
clear what the vice president talked
about we now can see every admission
every day and i want to thank the
hospitals who from
july have been sending us that data and
improving that data and working with cdc
so that we can see new admissions we can
see inpatient status we can see ccu
icu status and we can see who's being
admitted by age group
right now it's about 50 50 between those
between
40 and 69 and those over 70.
but you can see that we have some areas
of the country in the hot
red bright pink and these are the
darkest red or those
states that have more than 21 percent of
their hospitals are covid patients
and the light pink is between 16 and 20
percent
and the light orange between 12 and 15
but you do see that they're still states
in the green areas and to all of those
states
that have not seen this surge to really
increase your testing among
asymptomatics by setting up these
sentinel populations
when we did the 45 days to
stop the spread and we asked each state
to follow the grading criteria
part of that gating criteria included
looking for asymptomatic cases with
these new antigen tests we have the
capacity
to really expand testing to find those
cases and stop that spread
in the meantime as we started with
we stopped the surge in the south
through very
targeted mitigations that start with
mass
start with physical distancing but also
include decreasing those friends and
family gatherings
where people come together and
unknowingly spread the virus
and i want to thank the mayors of miami
miami city and miami county
who they were the ones that first in the
summer really found
how much asymptomatic spread was
occurring in household gatherings
and so as you bring together individuals
remember what the vice president talked
about
every american needs to be vigilant in
this moment
because we know that when you are we can
mitigate this virus and stop this spread
together
great thank you dr burks and as you can
see
with particularity on a state-by-state
basis we're
want the american people to know that we
have we have eyes on your local hospital
uh we know about admissions we know
about the availability of icu beds and
we know about supplies
and from very early on at the
president's direction we stood up the
greatest national mobilization since
world war ii
and i want the american people to know
that that continues
to this moment and general david sanford
who's been with us every step of the way
is going to
brief you on the status of our supply
chain
and the reserves that we have in our
ongoing efforts to make sure that our
our hospitals and health care facilities
have the resources and the support
to meet this moment general
mr vice president thank you sir dr burks
thank you ma'am
so we are in a much better place and
continue to improve upon that capability
you'll see from the slides behind me
that we have
continued to grow our national stockpile
but also our fema stocks
to meet the requirements uh laid out by
our states
and by our populations we continue to
expand upon these to bridge
the vaccine delivery to continue to
protect
our american population since the late
summer we have grown our personal
protective equipment capabilities
10 to 15 times over what they were
pre-coded
and can continue to grow capability to
meet the surge requirements that we may
expect
from the current caseload as you can see
behind me
around the third column or fourth column
we have four months of surge capability
based on current current case diagnosis
just for n95 masks and we continue to
grow that capability more mass being
added
every month the strategic national
stockpile and our fema
stocks are ready to be the backstop when
our states
require assistance and that's all built
upon a foundation
of a strong domestic medical industrial
base
something where we've been able to
expand upon or build in some cases
almost from scratch
using our defense production act and
other cares act authorities
to provide the capabilities for our
american people not just
now but into the future and for future
crisis or medical events going down
we go next slide please this is not done
alone we continue to work with our
states
on a recurring basis our fema
administrator is constantly engaged with
the governors
or their staffs we reach out to both our
regional administrators
to the state medical or health
department officials
and both to the emergency management
officials in the state to find out what
their needs are to help overcome their
challenges
and to grow the state's stockpiles as
that relates to our
federal emergency management mandate of
local execution state management federal
support
as you saw in the previous slide and as
you'll see on this color-coded map
between our states and the federal
government we stand in a much better
position than we were
just a month ago and certainly more than
than four or five months ago
to meet the surging ppe demands of
our of our nation and this is not
something that we're we're sitting and
continuing just to watch it is something
that we're continuing to grow upon
and continuously analyze so that we can
stay ahead
of the increases and make sure that
we're either procuring and we have a ppe
on the on the way to meet the surging
cases
i'll turn it over to dr fauci and
general parker
well done well done uh with that i'm
going to invite dr tony fauci to come up
and
share his thoughts on the development of
a vaccine which is giving such great
hope
but i i trust that the panels that you
just showed us
encourage the american people to know
that we're going to continue to work
around the clock to make sure your local
hospital
has the resources and supplies that you
need
to meet this moment but i think we all
know that we ultimately put this
pandemic in the past the day that we
have a safe and effective vaccine
we've been making a historic progress
through operation warp speed with our
private partners
uh and dr tony fauci and nih have been
absolutely integral to that so
i've asked dr fatchi to update you on
the status of vaccine development
and then uh and then we will have
general gus purna who is coordinating
the distribution plan
for operation warp speed working with
every state and territory in america to
be ready
on day one to distribute vaccines as
soon as they're available to give you a
brief outline
on that plan so dr fauci
thank you very much mr vice president uh
as i was sitting there i was recalling
that
about seven or eight months ago i start
i stood
at this exact spot at a time when there
was really an extraordinary
surge in cases in the northeastern part
of the country
in new york city and i said that if the
virus was left to its own devices it
would cause
a considerable degree of devastation
because that's what pandemic
viruses do it's a very powerful force
and you've heard about that and what we
need to do about it
from dr burks however i also said if
some of you can remember
that there's an opposing force to that
and that opposing force
is us you and i being able to do
certain things like mitigation with
public health measures
again which was just mentioned by dr
burks
but there's another opposing force to
that and that's a vaccine
and historically if you look at highly
efficacious and effective
vaccines through the years they've
crushed
formidable outbreaks like smallpox
like polio like measles so in the next
couple of minutes let me tell you about
what we have
now and what's going to happen in the
next few months
as you well know operation warp speed
has been uh supporting directly and
indirectly six
candidate vaccines four of which are
either
in or completed phase three clinical
trial
i want to briefly tell you about two of
them because
you have to be interested in this it is
extraordinarily impressive
two of the vaccines one by moderna and
one by
the company fisa have completed trials
and the f and the efficacious
vaccine efficacy point is extraordinary
with regard to pfizer it was 95 percent
efficacious not only against
disease that's just clinically
recognizable disease
but severe disease there were ten cases
of severe disease
one in the vaccine nine in the placebo
for the moderna trial it was 94.5
percent
efficacious 11 severe events
zero in the vaccine 11 in the placebo
for those of you not acquainted with the
field of vaccinology
that is extraordinary that is almost to
the level
of what we see with measles which is 98
effective
so that's what we're dealing with the
question is
what about how that is going to be
rolled out
i used the word efficacious that means
what happens in a clinical trial
the word effective means is what the
ultimate impact
of that vaccine is going to be on
society and the only way you can get
an effective program is when people take
the vaccine
and we're going to be talking to you
about that and i hear a lot now when we
made these announcements this past
monday
and then two mondays ago about some
reticence of people well did you rush
this was this too
fast is it really safe and is it really
efficacious
the process of the speed did not
compromise at all
safety nor did it compromise scientific
integrity
it was a reflection of the extraordinary
scientific
advances in these types of vaccines
which allowed us to do things in months
that actually took years before so i
really want to settle that concern
that people have about that what about
the decision of the data who looked at
the data
was that some force that was maybe
trying to put something over on you
no it was actually an independent body
of people who have no allegiance to
anyone not to the administration
not to me not to the companies that
looked at the data and deemed it to be
sound
now that data will be examined very
carefully by the fda
who together with a advisory committee
the vaccine and related biological
products advisory committee or verppac
are going to look at that before the fda
makes the decision
about putting this forth for an
emergency use authorization
or ultimately for a license so we need
to put the rest
any concept that this was rushed in an
inappropriate way
this is really solid now
what does that mean for us we now as the
vice president said
are telling you that help is on the way
which has two aspects to it it means
that we need to actually double down on
the public health
measures as we're waiting for that help
to come which will be soon we'll be
getting vaccine doses into people
at high priority at the end of december
we're not talking about shutting down
the country we're not talking about
locking down
we're talking about intensifying the
simple public health measures
that we all talk about mask wearing
staping distance avoiding
congregate settings doing things to the
extent that we can outdoors versus
indoors if we do that
we'll be able to hold things off until
the vaccine
comes now i've used that metaphor that
the cavalry is on the way
if you're fighting a battle and the
cavalry is on the way you don't stop
shooting you keep going until the
cavalry gets here and then you might
even want to continue
fighting and then finally one other
final thing about it
the very impressive efficacy 94.5
and 95 of a vaccine should
motivate individual to realize that this
is something you want to participate in
so we're going to be talking to you
about it
likely here in the future about why it's
important as these vaccine doses roll
out
why we have to do two things continue
the public health
measure and get vaccinated when the
vaccine becomes available
thank you
excuse me mr vice president thank you
very much for this opportunity
so i've been asked to highlight uh our
way ahead on distribution of the vaccine
as just talked about by dr fauci and
before that
vice president pence you know we are
here today because our mission
was clear in our mission to dr monsef
salawi
my co-leader and really heavily
responsible for our success
we are here today because we focused on
developing manufacturing and
distributing
a safe and effective vaccine and
therapeutics to the american people
our purpose is really clear save lives
and it has driven us
to this end state and that's why we're
here today a couple of things as we get
started in our planning
i will tell you that the planning began
almost immediately following
our ceremony in the rose garden on 15
may that monday
we started talking development
manufacturing and distribution
it's not a thought that we've had in the
last two weeks
it's required extensive planning and
detailed work by
a collaboration of individuals which
i'll talk about couple things we
decided up front one we were going to be
able to deliver the vaccine within 24
hours after
eua that is distribution to the entire
united states of america to include
territories and metropolitan cities
two we started with a foundation of
expertise
the cdc is the very best at planning and
executing
distribution of vaccines we took their
core competency
and we aligned it with the capability of
planners project managers
and those who could run campaigns
and together this organization has come
up with our strategy for distribution
third we took the capacity of the
industry
commercial industry and we brought them
into the fold
we wanted to utilize the capability and
the capacity
that is already established in america
that has a proven track record that
knows how to distribute vaccines
that understands the nuances of ultra
cold chain
requirements we knew if we brought
pfizer moderna mckesson
ups fedex cvs walgreen
and hundreds others together that we
would come up with the best solutions
because innovation towards our end state
was our only care
it wasn't about egos and it wasn't about
credit
it was about how do we solve this
complex problem it was
clear immediately following our initial
meetings with industry
that we had to have full collaboration
to my fourth point
with the jurisdictions and the states
they had to be
a big part of our planning sequence
so together ows cdc
industry and the states and
jurisdictions came up with the plan
that i'm going to talk to you about here
shortly it is
the effort that is almost so common
that you will recognize it because we do
it every year
we do it when we distribute influenza
vaccines
we do it when other vaccines are being
distributed the difference is
now we're pushing mass volume of a new
vaccine
and so we needed to have a strategy that
was collaborated
at all levels with all organizations in
order to execute
the last thing we needed to do was we
had to create a system to see ourselves
we had to be able to see inside of every
territory
state metropolitan city understand where
the vaccine was
from fill finish site to distribution
warehouses
down to administration sites so not only
could we maintain the flow of vaccine
but we could account for vaccine that
was being
administered that way we can keep the
flow
to the american people in a steady
drumbeat
as we go forward first slide please
we will distribute the vaccine
accordingly i direct you to the right
side of the slide
this is our end state this is where we
want the vaccines to be
we want the vaccines down at the places
where the american people are
comfortable
at our hospitals our doctor's offices
down at cvs
walgreens down at the long care
health care facilities places where
people are comfortable going
so that's where we started end state
then we went back
to pfizer and moderna we laid out the
guidelines that i gave you
and with the collaboration of them and
the commercial industry for distribution
we came up with our plan it's relatively
simple
we take uh the pfizer vaccine they are
capable of distributing on their own
they will utilize fedex and ups in order
to execute distribution
simultaneously we will ship ancillary
kits
needles syringes alcohol wipes
and the diluting required for the
vaccine to meet the vaccine
at the end state facilities that we're
talking about
for mckesson or for moderna vaccine what
we're going to do
is we're going to meet up the vaccine
with the ancillary kits
at a distribution warehouse we're going
to put them together
and then we're going to distribute
through fedex and ups
down to our administration sites
so in simple terms we're taking it from
fill finish
we're cut we're bringing together all
the requirements for administering the
vaccine
and then we're sending it down to the
distribution sites
any place that a state wants to
administer the vaccine
as long as they're enrolled right into
our process
we can distribute the vaccine we can
distribute the pfizer vaccine
at a minimum of 975 doses
and the modern vaccine at a minimum of
100 doses
we can go to one place in the state or
we can go to 10 000 places in the state
the capability and the capacity exists
because we came together
in a whole of america approach it is
this
effort that i can look you in the face
and say to you
eua comes 24 hours later vaccines will
be distributed out to the american
people
and be ready for administration to this
end
our mission is as i stated safe and
effective
vaccines to the american people and we
need to do it in the most timely manner
possible
because it is all about lives thank you
mr vice president
general how many uh how many kids have
already done
mr vice president we already have over a
million kits of both
uh the kits that we'll need for the
pfizer vaccine as well as the modern
vaccines
different 100 100 yeah excuse me 100
million thank you
sure
general carter thank you and as he said
from the time president trump announced
operation warp speed
general perna and his team have been
working literally around the clock
to build the distribution plan that you
see that's in effect
and i and i hope you all heard that i
asked him how many of those kits have
already been
manufactured for merging with um
merging with the moderna product and
they've already assembled 100 million
kits
that are ready to go and that's the
supplies that are necessary for
administering
the vaccine i i must tell you having
received my latest briefing today over
at fema
from operation war speed i think every
american can be proud
of uh of the fact that we have a plan in
place
that the moment that the fda concludes
that that vaccine is safe and effective
we have a system in place to begin
within 24 hours
shipping that vaccines to hospitals
healthcare facilities
and 24 hours after that literally
injecting
that vaccine into americans and
we'll also be continuing to develop the
prioritization working with states
about their plans and maybe bob redfield
of cdc will reflect on that
as well in a moment cdc will create a
recommendation for
priorities of who's to be immunized but
if history is a teacher we know that
we'll focus on those most vulnerable
we'll focus on our healthcare
workers and and first responders um
at the at the early going but it's uh
it's it's truly inspiring to me to see
the incredible work that
operation warp speed has done and
general purna i want to thank you for uh
for your dedication with that as i said
we've continued from the very beginning
to operate an approach at the federal
level that is federally supported
state managed locally executed and will
continue to respect decisions that state
governments are making
in efforts to slow the spread
but but to be very clear
president trump has been very clear that
we do not support another national
lockdown and do not believe it is
necessary i think dr fauci actually
reflected again on
we're not calling for a national
lockdown and we won't
but beyond that uh there have been some
actions taken in
jurisdictions around the country with
regard to closing schools
um i wanted the american people to know
that uh
it is uh it is the position of this task
force uh
of this administration and of the cdc
that we do not
need to close our schools i want to
invite dr redfield to come forward to
speak about that
but i want to emphasize what he's
reminded our task force of many times
that actually
at no point in this pandemic has the cdc
ever recommended closing schools
and the more we've learned about about
this virus the more it's simply
affirmed that we think our kids belong
in the classroom
we're absolutely committed to continue
to provide resources
so our kids our teachers our
administrators can safely
safely get back to school but with that
let me introduce
dr redfield and with him dr eleanor
mccann's katz at hhs who
is an extraordinary leader she's going
to speak about the unintended
consequences of
of shutting our kids out of the
classroom around america
and and then i'll have the secretary i
have some closing remarks
dr redfield
thank you mr vice president i think it's
important first for me to emphasize
what you've heard already is that we're
not defenseless
against this virus mask works
social distancing works hand washing
works
being smart about crowds particularly
indoor
works this is strategic uses
and dr burke said of testing
to identify the silent epidemic to
identify the asymptomatic infection so
that they can be
pulled out of the transmission cycle
works
another point that i want to make is
that we need to follow the data
we should be making data-driven
decisions
when we talk about what we're doing for
institutions
or what we're doing for commercial
closures
for example as was mentioned last spring
cdc did not recommend
school closures nor did we
nor did we recommend their closures
today i will say back in
the spring there was limited data today
there's extensive data
that we have we've gathered over the
last two to three months to confirm
that k-12 schools can operate with
face-to-face
learning and they can do it safely
and they can do it responsibly the
infections that we've identified in
schools
when they've been evaluated were not
acquired in schools
they were actually inquired in the
community and in the household
today as dr burke said our big threat
for transmission is not the public
square
it's small family gatherings family
gatherings where
people become more comfortable they
remove their face mask
and they get together and it's just
silent epidemic
that begins to transmit but it's not
inter-school transmission
the truth is for kids k-12 one of the
safest place they can be
from our perspective is to remain in
school
and it's really important that uh
following the data making sure we don't
make emotional
decisions about what to close
and what not to close and i'm here to
say clearly the data
strongly supports that k-12 schools
as well as institutes of higher learning
really are not where we're having our
challenges and it would be
counterproductive from my point of view
from a public health point of view just
in containing the epidemic
if there was an emotional response to
say let's close
the schools finally you know i wanted to
echo what has been said by the vice
president and dr fauci
is we are seeing the light at the end of
the tunnel
where we are to now and this is why now
more than ever
as was said by dr burks and dr fauci
myself
now more than ever we're asking all
americans
all americans to redouble their effort
efforts to be vigilant to embrace mass
social distancing
hand washing our advice about about
crowds and really to support
using the data to make decisions
in their communities particularly as
relates to
k-12s and institutes of higher learning
these clearly the data support that it's
really important from public health
perspective both from the pandemic
as well as what we'll you'll hear about
in a minute
that these schools stay open finally i
just want to
end on a clear message of confidence
that i'm confident that we're going to
emerge
successful and bring this pandemic to an
end
i don't have any doubt in that but today
we need we need all of us to go
all in go all in with
face coverings social distancing hand
washing smartness about crowds
doing our part to help identify the
silent epidemic
and i have confidence that at the end of
the day we're going to get
a very achievable goal which is to get
this pandemic under
control thank you mr vice president
thank you
thank you mr vice president in my role
as assistant secretary for mental health
and substance use
i feel very strongly about the need to
protect and promote the mental health of
all americans
as a psychiatrist i'm continually
thinking about the mental health effects
of this
unprecedented situation and how best to
mitigate the impact
individuals across our country are
living with stress
that they have likely never experienced
we must find a way
to best alleviate that stress without
ignoring the fact
that our nation faces a very real and
deadly virus
i often think about this in the context
of our country's children
i leave the substance abuse and mental
health services administration or samsa
which is the only federal agency whose
primary charge is addressing
mental and substance use disorders
across the country
where better to start in addressing this
challenge than with our nation's young
people
protecting and also fostering the social
and emotional well-being of children is
critical
not only to their own development but
also to the development of healthy
families
communities and a healthy and productive
society
the work that schools and school
personnel do daily
is valuable beyond any words i can
deliver we know that
in addition to education schools provide
our children
a profound sense of security and
stability
the structure and safety of schools are
integral to our children's whole health
the role of the school cannot be
overstated however we also cannot
overstate the need to
address the fear uncertainty and safety
considerations with returns to school
i understand that parents and teachers
may feel great anxiety
that is why we must put into place the
safety measures we know work
we must use masks we must enforce social
distancing
we must employ creative and innovative
ways to limit the number of children and
teachers in the building at any given
time
there are tools we have and we must
think through how best to use them
to keep our schools open we know
that over 7.4 million children in this
country
live with serious emotional disturbances
and over
60 percent receive services from the
school system
we know that children with disabilities
are losing ground with the closure of
schools
we know that millions of children across
the country are experiencing child abuse
and neglect that goes
undetected due to lack of contact with
school personnel
who serve as mandatory reporters we must
work together to address these issues
i believe strongly that we need schools
to open in communities whose data
indicate it's safe to do so
but we cannot forget the protection of
our teachers and school staff
if they don't feel it's safe to return
to work
it will not help to open schools we must
ensure that teachers
school staff and parents are engaged in
the solutions
that we ultimately choose just as i'm
suggesting
that we engage our teachers i suggest
also that we recognize the very real
mental health considerations of what you
may have heard called pandemic fatigue
the engagement of americans all over the
country and slowing the spread of the
virus is a strategy i think we should
all consider
again we know masks work but we know
that some americans aren't sure and may
not be as compliant as we'd like
this is gravely frustrating for local
officials but rather than punishing or
sanctioning
what if we employ a different technique
what if we recognize the psychological
aspects of the fatigue and try to
reinforce positive behavior
with rewards with rewards rather than
solely sanction what we deem to be bad
behavior
for example we know that compliance on
college campuses has been a challenge
and individuals in this age group are a
potential source of spread
what if college has implemented a random
reward system for math squaring
this could be as simple as implementing
a small gift card being given out to a
student wearing a mask
this technique known as contingency
management has had great success
in the behavioral health care treatment
communities
i offer it as a consideration which
acknowledges the psychological aspects
of our life's changes
i want to conclude by saying that the
physical effects of coronavirus are very
real
and this virus has brought along with
its stress anxiety
and fear that you may have never felt
before
covet 19 has brought devastating loss of
life to families across the nation in
addition
to those who have lost lives to the
infection itself
there are those of you who have what i
call
covet related deaths in your family
these are not deaths by
infection but death by suicide
or death by drug overdose during this
pandemic
please know that we have not forgotten
you or your loss
your loss is great and my job is to do
all i can to prevent additional families
from experiencing that loss to the
parents and teachers who are afraid and
confused
that fear and anxiety is real and it's
stressful
to the people who are without a job and
unsure of your next steps
your stress is real too the stress of
this situation can often feel too great
to handle and we take very seriously
the need to ensure that all americans
know that there is help
and there is hope we are doing all we
can
to ensure that the mental health care
system in our nation
remains open and ready to serve
as you struggle with these great
stressors especially during the holiday
season
please try to stay connected to loved
ones
please reach out to friends and family
and please know that samhsa's national
suicide prevention lifeline is available
to help at any time at
critically 800-273-8255 and we want to
do all we can to protect it
well thank you mr vice president it's
good to see all of you
the doctors have well covered the
serious state of the
epidemiological evidence that we have
and they've talked about the steps that
we
can and should be taking but they've
also talked about the steps that aren't
evidence-based
that we should not be taking right now
we are much better prepared today than
we were months ago
general sanford talked about our ppe
supplies
our ventilator supplies the vice
president talked about our expanded
testing capacity nationwide reach of
over 120 million tests available in the
month of november alone
70 million of them point-of-care tests
we've improved dramatically our quality
of care in our hospitals our ability to
treat people
who suffer from covet my message to the
american people
is to hang in there with us take the
simple steps
that the doctors have talked about today
because there is light at the end of the
tunnel
this isn't forever thanks to president
trump's operation warp speed
we have got such a brighter future ahead
and i want to see everyone get there
president trump called me in and said
alex
all the experts are saying it's going to
be optimistically 18 months for a
vaccine
over a year for therapeutics you know
the drug industry you know drug
development
could we shorten that is there anything
we could do and i said yes there is
and we crafted the greatest
biopharmaceutical research development
manufacturing distribution mobilization
and partnership with the defense
department
with the constant personal unwavering
support of president trump
or delivering results on that this is
thanks to the leadership people
people like general purna running
operation warp speed bringing the
complete logistics and operations and
procurement power of the defense
department to the table
and it's thanks to people like dr monsef
slawy
probably the world's greatest vaccine
developer who's dedicated his complete
life and talents
to this work for the american people and
we're seeing the results
they said it couldn't be done but 10
months
into this novel pathogen hitting our
shores
last week we approved eli lilly's
monoclonal antibody
we shipped product that very afternoon
to patients
and already over 60 000 courses of
therapy
have been delivered regeneron's
combination monoclonal antibody
is pending at the fda right now
as we've talked about over the last two
weeks we've seen just unprecedented
historic
news about vaccines two vaccines
each with 95 percent efficacy
rivaling the 98 efficacy
of our measles vaccine produced in some
of the largest vaccine clinical trials
ever conducted in history over 40 000
patients
in each of these clinical trials
demonstrating
good safety profiles
this was done in 10 10 months 10
months and now pfizer's partner bioentec
has announced that tomorrow they intend
to file for emergency use authorization
at the fda we would expect to see
mederna
filing soon also
we also have this comprehensive
distribution plan that general purnell
walked through
that builds on the public-private
partnership between the united states
and these incredible private sector
partners with a goal to make the
distribution of this vaccine as
convenient to you as the flu vaccine is
and working in partnership with our
states because the states know the
situation on the ground
and we work to support them and we will
ship
millions of doses of vaccine within
24 hours of fda approval
so my message is hope and help are on
the way
operation warp speed is already
delivering and it's going to keep
delivering in the days
and weeks ahead thank you very much mr
vice president
let me say i my hope is that americans
looking on and all of you
responsible for sharing the news
and know that this team
working in cooperation with our states
with the cooperation of the american
people
has made great progress and we're
getting there
we're getting there america and as i
said at the outset let me say i hope
it's more in evidence
as you hear from this team about the
abundance of supplies that are available
today for our hospitals our ability to
track
what's happening at your local hospital
to make sure it has the ppe and the
equipment and supplies to provide the
health care
that your family may need i hope
i hope as you heard about the
extraordinary distribution plans
of operation warp speed uh and the
confidence uh
uh that dr fauci expressed today and the
news that
one of those research companies is going
to submit an emergency use authorization
tomorrow on the very first
vaccine that we are literally literally
we could well be just a matter of a few
short weeks away from a vaccine being
available
across this country for the most
vulnerable among us and for those that
are caring for them in our hospitals
and our clinics i hope everything you've
heard today gives evidence of what i
said at the start that america has never
been more prepared to combat this virus
but let me be clear as i close we all
have a role to play
in the days ahead and you heard this
team say as we
as we see that finish line as we see
light at the end of the tunnel as
president trump often says
and you should see evidence here that we
are rounding the corner to that day that
we have a vaccine
for the american people we do want to
encourage every american to continue to
do your part
wash your hands practice social
distancing
wear a mask when social distancing isn't
possible
do your part to put the health of your
family the health of your neighbors to
help the people in your community first
we are all in this together and as i've
said many times from this podium over
many many months
i know that with the cooperation of the
american people with our incredible
doctors and nurses and first responders
with the extraordinary partnership of
federal and state and local health
officials
and with god's help we will get through
this
and we will get through this together
democracy you're all undermining the
democratic elections
every one of you why is that you won't
work with the transactions